- What's up, y'all?
We're back with Anthony Mackie.
Give it up.
(distant audience cheering)
Anthony's new movie is
called, We Have a Ghost.
You can see it now on Netflix.
We all know ghosts are
notoriously creepy, ya'll.
So, we thought this would be a good time
for another round of
What's Creepin' Up on Me.
(upbeat background tune riffing)
♪ What's creepin' up on me ♪
(distant Kelly chuckling)
Get it, Jesse.
- [Anthony] Good.
- Are you good at games?
- [Anthony] I am very bad at games.
And I have a stack of games, and losses,
to prove it to myself.
- [Kelly] Oh my God, I love it.
Ok, well, we're on a team.
Here's how this game works.
I'm good at games, generally.
Anthony will start with
his back to the screen,
and I'll give him clues about
what's creeping up behind him
without saying the name of the thing.
Then we're gonna switch sides,
and Anthony will give me clues.
Are you ready?
- I gotta focus.
- If we can correctly guess
10 things total in two rounds,
the audience will win a prize.
Do you wanna let them down?
(distant excited audience cheering)
If we can't, I blame Anthony.
(distant audience cheering)
Let's get into position.
Okay, okay.
- That's so not fair.
- Okay, okay.
No, it's gonna be great.
It's gonna be great.
Okay, so here we go.
And...
Go!
Ooo, what the hell?
(distant audience chuckling)
Oh, oh!
- You have to talk to me.
- A big, a big thing in
the forest that people say
they've seen, but it's not
real, but might be real.
- A yeti.
Uh, big foot.
(background bell chiming)
- Another word.
Okay, yeah.
(distant audience cheering)
Oh, this is a...
It's what's inside my skin.
What makes, what's on what's
underneath all my skin.
Like, like...
- Muscles.
- No, even the muscles are attached to it.
- Blood.
Skeleton.
- Yes!
(distant audience excited cheering)
- Oh, oh, and it's doing this.
It's, it's...
- Vampire. - moving,
it's a moving skeleton.
- Moving skeleton.
- It's a, it's a,...
Oh my god.
Okay.
- Moving. - Okay.
(Kelly excited squealing)
Josh Brolin in Marvel.
- Thanos.
- Yes!
(distant audience excited cheering)
(Anthony chuckling)
Move!
Oh, this is, oh, this is like
a, a, a, a, a purr thing.
A thing that purrs.
- A cat.
- Okay, but then also it does this.
- Catfish.
- Yes.
(distant audience excited cheering)
Okay, okay.
This, what the hell is that?
Oh.
This is, snakes are on this person's head.
- Medusa.
- Yes.
(distant audience excited cheering)
- Okay, okay.
Oh, this is, ooo, if death
comes, this person shows up.
(distant air horn blaring)
- The grim reaper.
- We got it.
I feel like got it.
(background bell chiming)
(distant audience excited cheering)
They move slow.
Okay,...
It's a lot harder than it looks.
- Aww, man.
I've never heard somebody
say, "ooo" so much since
my first child.
(distant audience chuckling)
You get that now.
- Ooo, uh, ooo, ooo.
(show hosts chuckling)
I was like, I couldn't think.
I got six with you, it's good, it's good.
- All right, so all I need is four?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
Okay. - [Anthony] Okay.
All right, all right.
- You ready?
Don't fail.
- [Anthony] If I curse,
you can bleep it out.
- [Kelly] We can bleep it out.
- "Don't fail."
- Okay,...
go.
- Ooo, so,...
- You said, "ooo".
- This is the hardest!
Okay.
- Rock.
- So, if you see a ghost,
the, the apparition
that the ghost is, it's called a...
It's a religious, it's
in you, your soul...
- Spirit.
- Yes.
(distant audience excited cheering)
(background bell chiming)
- Ooo, so this is a James,
this was a James Bond movie.
It has eight legs.
It's in the water.
- It's a spider.
- It's in the water.
- Oh, octopus.
Eight legs...
(background tonal beeping)
(distant audience excited cheering)
(Anthony laughing)
- Really?
Okay, it's a four-legged
animal, not a cat,
but a...
- Dog, dog.
- Okay, it is a, a one of those,
and it can read your future.
- A dog, a dog...
- With a ball... - palm reader.
- with light.
- A dog,...
Oh, what are those people called?
- A dog, uh, fortune teller.
- Okay, no, no, no.
(background bell chiming)
A seer.
(distant audience excited cheering)
A dog seer.
Okay.
- Oh, this is so dirty.
I have so many dirty jokes.
(distant audience laughing)
Okay, this was a movie back
in the day with a large snake,
and...
- Anaconda.
- Yes!
(distant audience excited cheering)
(distant air horn blaring)
(distant Anthony chuckling)
- What you gonna do with that snake?
That is Jon Voight.
(Anthony chuckling)
I love that movie.
- Oh!
- That's literally quotable.
"What you gonna do with that snake?"
It was.
I just love that you made
fun of me for saying "ooo",
and literally you went, "Oh, oh,"
(Anthony chuckling)
(distant audience chuckling)
(Kelly chuckling)
You did the same thing.
- They gave me way harder stuff.
- Whatever.
- A dog dressed as a psychic?
(distant audience chuckling)
- Yeah, no, that was, I'm
really glad that wasn't mine.
- I'm gonna find out who did that.
- [Kelly] Yeah.